[Music]
so we have tremendous expertise in front
of us and we are going to discuss a
whole variety of areas to do with the
category of gender is it still useful
where is it useful how might we overcome
it and we have three very distinguished
speakers who are going to be bringing
that to us today on my right-hand side
here we have dr. Finn Makai who is the
founder of the London feminist Network
but is now lecturer at the University of
West of England and in sociology and
author most recently of a book called
radical feminism on my left is Angela
eagle
member of parliament label Member of
Parliament for Wallasey and on the
left-hand side just beyond we are
delighted to have with us professor
Patricia McCormack who specializes in
continental philosophy she teaches at
Anglia Ruskin University she publishes
and lectures on sexuality queer theory
feminism and ethics and her latest book
is the animal catalyst to start us off
I'm going to turn to fin Makai if I may
and ask fin gender is a term that
clearly has had an awful lot of use and
it's also traveled a very long distance
in terms of the way we think about it
but is it still useful or are we in a
sense outgrowing it okay well thank you
I think it's important before we get
into the debate here to make a very
clear distinction between the two terms
gender and sex so these two terms out
there in the world are always conflated
often wrongly so biological sex refers
to physical biological bodily
characteristics it's a descriptive label
that we put on to people's bodies
usually at Birth based on biological
features and currently we recognize
female male and intersex as those labels
so gender however is not biological
gender is the term used to refer to
masculinity femininity androgynous camp
unicorn all whatever
other sorts of ways people might want to
define their expression and their style
and their personal identity it is deeply
felt it's a key part of most of our
identities and in that sense it is real
but it is not born it is made gender is
a social construct that changes over
time and place and culture babies are
not born macho or boyish or girlish
babies are not born liking football or
frocks they are not born with a
biological drive to sit with their legs
apart versus crossed they don't have a
fancy for long hair and makeup in the
womb they don't they're not born
neurologically predisposed to pursuing
either low paid caring work or
construction apprenticeship what is
considered appropriately masculine or
feminine clothing jobs hobbies roles
changes in line with the socio-economic
and political climate
so while around the world babies have
been born with pretty similar bodies
pretty similar biological
characteristics forever the same cannot
be said for gender gender fluxes and
changes so it cannot and should not be
described as biological or natural or
fixed or in the brain all these other
sort of essentialist claims that are
sometimes made for gender so coming back
to the question the end of the debate I
can see why it may seem and feel radical
to use terms and claim identities such
as gender fluid or non-binary for
example but these labels can be
counterproductive because they can end
up strengthening the very institutions
that they suggest that they wish to take
apart so the category of non-binary for
example reinforces the binary in a sense
because in order for there to be a
non-binary there has to be a binary in
the first place and I would suggest
actually that gender comes naturally to
no one
everyone works hard at their gender most
people are trying to
be masculine or feminine and worried
that they are not masculine or feminine
enough look at the billions spent on gym
membership beauty products cosmetic
surgery by men and women the numbers of
young people boys and girls self-harming
extreme dieting from younger and younger
ages suffering eating disorders taking
illegal muscle building steroids or
overtraining in the gym these brutal
statistics also illustrate that point
gender is a profoundly political
category it is intended to distinguish
within our system of sex rank so the
answer cannot be just to add more and
more categories to the rainbow of gender
if anywhere along the spectrum women are
still being oppressed by men women being
paid less because they have an F on
their birth certificate men being
refused parent or leave because they
have an M on theirs
fetuses aborted because they are girls
men getting away with rape this system
of sex rank has to end and that can only
be done through collective liberation
movements it cannot be done individually
alone through personal expression which
calls only for recognition of
increasingly increasingly diverse
personal identities so just to be clear
that last point Finn you are saying this
struggle cannot be carried out simply
through individual recognition of
individual preference there's a lot of
good things about the massive cultural
shift we're seeing in the understanding
of the fixity of sex sexuality gender
and sex that's a really interesting and
powerful and real shift but we mustn't
throw the baby out with the bathwater so
to speak not to be overly by a
biological about it we mustn't throw
away collective liberation movements
because sadly we still need them thank
you very much that very clear point you
can most plenty there that we're going
to come back to in just a few minutes
but not before I've turned to Angela
eagle Angela gender is it a category
that you still find useful productive or
fruitful or do we need to move beyond it
well I
to say I agree a lot with Finn's
analysis there I mean there are issues
about empowerment about gender
stereotypes about the roles that
historically have been allotted to men
and women across the world not only in
our own society that we need to liberate
ourselves from I for one believe for
example that the Enlightenment never
included women I think that Mary
Wollstonecraft used to write a little
bit about that and if we did refound and
completely enlightenment by including
women their views their opinions their
life experiences then we would have a
better society
we'd have a better understanding of what
rationality was we would have heard and
included women's voices and of course
that goes for all other marginalized
voices as well because the more that we
can hear and respond to people's life
experiences and accommodate them in our
political calculations in our view of
what a just society should be the more
likely we are to create a more humane
and sustainable society so the battle
that women have had over years to get
reasonable recognition for their for
their needs in inner society to be
liberated from the very rigid
stereotypes that have prevented women
from from achieving their full potential
the better our society will be I became
a feminist and one that fought for
liberation when I was eight years old I
remember it very well the actual moment
I went along to play chess - the Formby
junior chess competition and because I
discovered that I could play chess and
my dad had carted me along to this
competition and me and my twin sister
were the only girls there
playing and I sat down all thinking the
world was fantastic and my feet ready
for me to go and explore had no idea
that there was a problem until I sat
down opposite this little boy who looked
at me in horror and said this can't be
right girls don't play chess and he
actually started panicking and first of
all I thought what is he going on about
and then I thought he's frightened of
losing to a girl that is what's going on
here
so obviously I beat him and I won the
tournament and it was I realized there
was an even bigger problem when I was
awarded a Biggles book as the prize so
it was then that I was told that girls
brains were smaller than boys and
therefore they couldn't play chess and
they wouldn't ever be as good and some
of our best chess players in this
country still think that way by the way
and so then I thought right there's a
battle to be had here and that's when I
joined in so it sounds what you're
saying Angela as if gender the
construction of ideas for instance that
women can't play chess are still with us
still need to battle against we have not
yet in a point where we can go beyond
gender we are nowhere near that I would
love us to be able to go beyond those
kinds of gender stereotypes which turn
into economic reality it would be
fantastic I would put a big tick in that
box that opened up when I first went to
that chess tournament but we are nowhere
near we are actually going backwards in
a lot of places and in other areas of
the world virtually no progress has been
made so we've still got a huge issue of
gender stereotyping of teaching and
socializing boys and girls to be how
they are expected to be boys tough girls
empathetic it's oppressive to both sets
of people for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute's of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you